in our series the new normal we look at
how the pandemic is dramatically
changing our
everyday lives this morning we're
focusing on the world of live
music concerts tours and music festivals
around the world have been called off
over fears of
spreading the coronavirus now music
promoters and venues are
experimenting with new ways to provide
live entertainment in a socially
distanced way
as mark strossman shows us you don't
even have to leave
your car all right you guys going to
crank up your stereos a little bit
loud out there now singer-songwriter
andrew mcmahon
had never seen a concert like the one he
headlined last weekend
in anaheim california
[Music]
this sold out drive-in joe was his first
live performance in months
since kova 19 took center stage i think
looking out at a sea of cars you know
rather than a bunch of people crammed in
tight is a
is a new visual um you know i was
laughing that when people got excited
during the show they were horns honking
and stuff
i think people are missing being in a
space and feeling connected
socially distance entertainment it's one
solution for an industry
hit by the virus and fighting to survive
anywhere you look
one symptom is unmistakable when no
one's touring
no one's working you know 90 percent of
our business is not no longer
viable right now david lowell runs sales
at music matters
an atlanta production company 17 of its
20
employees are furloughed 15 million
dollars worth of lighting and sound
equipment
has sat collecting dust since march can
you really
expect business to approach what it was
until there's a vaccine
you know it depends on how creative the
promoters get
the world's biggest promoter of live
events is live nation
its opening drive-in series last weekend
featured country music star
brad paisley live nation's head of
venues told us
the new normal of concerts could one day
include
rapid testing of fans that would be
ideal because then i think
individuals would be uh you know feel
safer and would feel like they would be
able to
enjoy the experience knowing that you
know the entirety of the venue was
at tested three-night show outside the
city national grove in anaheim
each car had an assigned parking space
off to one side
a tailgate zone outside that zone
everyone wore
face masks at the bathroom there was a
temperature check
jordan harding is the venue's general
manager we don't want anybody that's
coming here to to get sick
but ultimately you know we've created an
environment where people can be
contained and safe and socially
distanced we've done the best we can but
we acknowledge
that you know there is some risk
involved to minimize that risk
fans could use a mobile app to order
food drinks
and merch all delivered right to their
parking spot
we literally parked our car and we have
our blocked off space so
i feel pretty safe we wouldn't go to
concert indoors right now so this is
perfect
[Music]
alt rock music often rebels in
surprising ways
but at the drive-in concert mcmahon's
fans conformed
they followed the rules you know i know
that that sounds like a crazy thing at a
rock and roll show to be like yay for
following the rules but
in this particular case if we want to be
able to do this we have to
to protect each other and be good
citizens like rock music
fans have to prove they can adapt
we're calling that the honcore it may be
the only way
live music has an encore in covet
america
for cbs this morning mark strassman
atlanta
i love the encore it's just so great to
see live music and people out there in
any form i do love the idea of the merch
and the beverages being delivered to
your car i love all of it if i had a
horn right now i'd be honking it i hope
that sticks around
long after the pandemic